[BACKGROUND VOICES]
RICK GOINGS >> Hi, Rick Goings, I'm Chairman
and CEO of Tupperware brands and part of the
Diversity Group here in-in Davos.
We just had a terrific meeting. I want to
comment on the President of the Philippines'
ah-glorious, wonderful message about diversity.
And we've learned in our company that-ah-diversity
and this whole thiing about gender parity
isn't just something that's altruistic and
nice to do. It's a source of competitive advantage.
So we've spent the last year kind of educating
as many people as we can across the world
on the differences between men and women-how
to leverage that very strong difference and
the challenge that-ah-each brings to the party.
Anyway, ah-we think we'll make more progress
this next year. Take care. Bye.